[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález a propósito
del regreso a clase de varios países en
el hemisferio norte para comenzar un
nuevo año académico vuelve a quedar
sobre la mesa si están dadas las
condiciones dado lo que estamos
atravesando a los países de américa
latina para hacer frente a la pandemia
del cobi 19 es momento de reducir o
eliminar la virtualidad para retomar las
clases presenciales el tema vuelve a ser
motivo de estudio también de análisis y
está enfrentando las posiciones de los
epidemiólogos los médicos los padres de
familia por supuesto las autoridades de
los países las autoridades locales y por
supuesto los maestros retomar las clases
presenciales es nuestro tema de debate
hoy aquí en france24 les voy a dar
algunos de los de los casos que hemos
empezado a presenciar en la región de
américa latina por ejemplo uruguay fue
el primer país de la región que retomó
la presencialidad de las clases a partir
del 29 de junio con alguna alternancia
con virtualidad después de un mes y
medio
registrado en las escuelas uruguayas que
haya contagios dentro de los planteles y
no hay contagios por parte de los
alumnos esta es una buena noticia para
la región y es el caso a seguir dadas
las condiciones que ha tenido uruguay a
lo largo del manejo de la pandemia en
estos cinco meses colombia todavía está
en el debate del área de bogotá la
capital que tiene unos cerca de ocho
millones y medio habitantes o más indicó
que regresará de forma escalonada a
mediados del mes de octubre costa rica
ya el ministerio que maneja el área
educativa en ese país indicó que costa
rica no regresará a las clases
presenciales en el año 2020 retomarán el
tema del debate a partir del año
entrante y cuba ha retomado en algunas
regiones algunas provincias van a
retomar las clases a partir de
septiembre con muy estrictas medidas de
seguridad excepto la habana en donde han
tenido que imponer nuevamente medidas de
bioseguridad y confinamiento por el
aumento los casos que se ha presentado
en los últimos días
jose goitía que es el corresponsal de
france 24 en la ciudad de la mar de la
habana nos envió el siguiente reporte
contándonos cómo está
situación de cara al inicio del nuevo
año académico en la isla de cuba
hace un mes las autoridades anunciaron
la reapertura del curso escolar el 1º de
septiembre en toda la isla mascarilla
distanciamiento obligatorio para el
personal y los alumnos se editó un
manual a cargo del ministerio de la
salud con estrictas consignas de
seguridad y se decretó un visto bueno
obligatorio para cada establecimiento la
ministra de educación ena elsa velázquez
recorrió todo el país para asegurarse de
la presencia de todos los recursos
necesarios en esto apareció un rebrote
en la habana mayabeque y artemisa si las
cifras de fallecidos no subió tanto 92
hasta hoy los casos positivos si se
multiplicaron y se decidió posponer el
retorno a clases para la provincia
citadas con las sanciones de un donald
trump en plena campaña electoral y el
paso esta semana de la tormenta tropical
laura la isla enfrenta una situación
extrema pero no puede pretender fallar
en los dos temas que siempre han sido
los favoritos
es un sistema socialista salud y
educación de hecho si quiere en todo el
país terminar el curso anterior y seguir
corrido el curso 2020 2021
aquí no hay debate sobre las mascarillas
llamadas nasobucos su uso fue
obligatorio desde la aparición de la
pandemia y eso en todas circunstancias
también se prevé sistematizar las
pesquisas en los centros educacionales
este sábado la ministra de educación
dará los últimos detalles y precisará el
plan para la capital y las provincias
confinadas donde se transmitirán clases
por televisión hasta la vuelta a la
normalidad
jose goitía reportando nos desde la
ciudad de la habana en cuba para
analizar este tema también hemos
invitado a la doctora ángela gentile ya
epidemióloga e infectóloga pediátrica
ella es jefa del departamento de
epidemiología del hospital de niños
ricardo gutiérrez asesor o al gobierno
de la república argentina en la creación
de los protocolos para las escuelas
también estaba con nosotros el señor
david pérez él es dirigente estudiantil
representante ante el consejo permanente
multisectorial para la implementación
del compromiso nacional por la educación
en la república de panamá también según
esta conversación el doctor riccardo
mercado de él es profesor e investigador
del centro de investigación e innovación
en educación superior de la universidad
veracruzana atiende desde la ciudad de
xalapa en el estado de veracruz en
méxico les recuerdo que sus opiniones
son muy importantes también para
nosotros deje sus comentarios todas sus
preguntas en france 24 guión al piso s y
arroba sant y luego deje los comentarios
con el numeral el debate
efe 24 tenemos los invitados tenemos el
tema podemos empezar entonces con las
preguntas y comienzo con la doctora
ángela gentile en doctora es momento de
regresar a las clases presenciales dado
el escenario que se está presentando
sobre todo allí en buenos aires en
argentina
bueno el país tiene escenarios
totalmente diferentes no es lo mismo lo
que pasa en el área metropolitana que
muchas de las provincias del país en
este momento siempre fue el epicentro la
zona de de tantos buenos aires- como el
conurbano pero en este momento un 25 por
ciento de los casos totales que se
generan en algunas localidades del
interior del país igualmente hay
provincias que se encuentran en fase 4 y
5 con buenas condiciones epidemiológicas
para el comienzo de clases y de hecho
hay algunas que ya han comenzado a
activar protocolos sobre todo en
escuelas rurales que sería como el
primer desafío los protocolos están
armados tanto para la ciudad como para
la provincia de buenos aires y para todo
el país fueron protocolos que se
consensuaron entre los ministros de
salud y educación de cada una de las
provincias porque este es un país
y por otra parte también se consensuó
con los gremios docentes es decir todo
el equipo educativo que se puso de
acuerdo para armar estos protocolos el
protocolo es muy minucioso contempla
escalonamiento contempla primero una
mezcla de virtual y presencial con
reingreso de los chicos sobre todo del
primer grado último grado de la primaria
1º y último grado de la secundaria en el
tema de los jardines o la educación
inicial es más desafiante y eso aún no
están terminados los protocolos pero sí
para todo lo que es la escuela primaria
y secundaria quizás luego podemos ver
minuciosamente algunos detalles pero
este protocolo realmente como contempla
todo lo que implica desde la entrada del
colegio primero la preparación porque no
se puede hacer on off hay que prepararse
y prepararse implica desde todo punto de
vista la infraestructura los protocolos
el conocimiento de los chicos y de las
familias porque los chicos tienen que
entender o transportarse a de esta
situación y cómo manejarla es decir toda
la preparación antes de estar importante
y lleva tanto tiempo y tanto trabajo de
todo el equipo con el hecho en siglos y
archibald es la pena también es recordar
cómo integrar todo este tipo de acciones
vamos a profundizar en el caso argentino
en unos minutos quiero darle la palabra
al doctor riccardo mercado en la ciudad
de xalapa en méxico me interesa este
caso porque también es un país federal
así como argentina es decir que cada
estado puede adoptar algunas políticas
independiente de la política que
dicta el gobierno central desde ciudad
de méxico y también porque este país
regreso a clases desde la virtualidad a
través de televisión hacia pocos días y
es un caso particular e interesante para
analizar adelante doctor cree usted
entonces que es el momento para haber
empezado a desmontar la virtualidad y
retomar la las clases presenciales
de una manera de pico ávila pérez
a las clases presenciales
esta experiencia se regresará a las
tareas periciales aparece el color verde
de este celular escoltas es decir
culturales en la tarea titánica ya que
ha emprendido el chiste para acceder
atender a más de 30 millones de
estudiantes de la cita de educación y
también del exterior
[Música]
a través de la televisión tener es una
experiencia única y levita la entrevista
que se está haciendo lo que se puede
hacer de otro era dejar a los chicos en
desatendidas méxico es un país
cómo utilizar ser acceso a las leyes y
así desde codificación desde alcanzar
activista del país seguir la televisión
era analizar el creciente del escenario
nuevas internet
despertar el interés y el acceso a
internet
[Música]
gratis
sencilla
el área de la educación superior y ante
la educación básica y yo previsible que
todas las universidades soliciten
en estas fechas el desnivel del clima a
distancia no va a haber instituciones
que empiecen el siglo xvii del ciclo
escolar interna presencial es también un
área red si bien se va a hacer y lester
se dice táctil las instituciones del
último la crisis que es verse para poder
aprovechar todas las tecnologías
disponibles doctora sentir en el caso de
argentina después de estos casi cinco
meses de pandemia de confinamiento en
buena parte de estos meses argentina
comenzó el proceso de la pandemia y
también estaba prácticamente comenzando
el año escolar después del receso de
verano es decir más o menos en marzo
abril estaban retomando las clases en la
república argentina después de las
vacaciones de verano que elecciones deja
la virtualidad después de estos cinco
meses que pueden ser tenidos en cuenta
para esa retoma definitiva de las clases
presenciales y de pronto pensando a
futuro para que quede institucionalizado
dentro del
modelos educativos
yo creo que lo virtual es un excelente
modelo educativo pero tenemos que
también pensar la accesibilidad del
recurso
hay muchísimas poblaciones vulnerables
en las que tiene creo que latinoamérica
también con una accesibilidad disminuida
se intentó hacer a través no sólo de
internet sino también usando televisión
u otro tipo de recursos pero
evidentemente las poblaciones más
vulnerables son las que han sufrido más
estas dificultades de conectividad de
hecho en la ciudad de buenos aires- se
han identificado en este momento 6500
chiquitos que han perdido conexión con
la escuela no sólo no tienen una
conectividad marcada sino que han
perdido el contacto con la escuela por
eso que realmente creo que si bien todo
lo que es estas nuevas tecnologías van a
tener un rol cada vez más importante y
creo que ha llegado para quedarse y
hemos aprendido todos a usarla cada vez
más creo que también es un desafío
a la comunidad de todas estas
herramientas para que todas puedan
acceder todos los chicos y las familias
puedan acceder en una forma con equidad
en una forma equitativa porque esto no
se da en forma del semejante en todo el
país incluso hay mejor accesibilidad en
los centros urbanos que en las áreas en
urbanas o rurales la experiencia fue
buena mucho esfuerzo docente muchas
ganas de colaborar pero creo que también
de aprendizajes de que hay muchas otras
cosas que no es sólo conectividad que
tenemos que trabajar fuertemente y que
estas son también las enseñanzas que ha
dejado la pandemia también igualmente
creo que dada la situación
epidemiológica probablemente el regreso
sea una combinación de virtual y
presencial y creo que nos debemos un
debate cuando entró terminen
precisamente para evaluar todo el uso de
esas nuevas tecnologías y ver cómo las
podemos aplicar y cómo podemos hacer
cada vez más la comunidad pueda acceder
a todo este tipo de beneficios y sin
duda alguna doctora uno de los grandes
desafíos y de las problemáticas que
quedó sobre la mesa a raíz de la
pandemia es la división tecnológica que
hay todavía en américa latina' el acceso
a los equipos para poderse conectar y
como usted dice acceder a las conexiones
no todas las zonas remotas tienen buenas
conexiones a internet principalmente que
les pueda acceder les puede permitir a
los estudiantes acceder a los contenidos
académicos para continuar con su
aprendizaje 1 a esta conversación a
carlos ballesteros él es presidente de
la confederación nacional de padres de
colombianos atiende desde la ciudad de
bogotá señor ballesteros gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 y quiero
que comencemos preguntando rápidamente
cuál es su balance que hace usted de
estos cinco meses de educación virtual
en colombia que es un país que está
dentro de los cinco destacados de la
región junto con chile uruguay y méxico
en el manejo de la educación a través de
la virtualidad ps
todas las a todos los problemas que
presentó allí la conexión para algunas
zonas remotas el acceso a los equipos
para los estudiantes y que el gobierno
presionó para que se desarrollaran
rápidamente los contenidos para la
virtualidad en solamente un espacio de
dos semanas
buena tarde para todos un cordial saludo
desde colombia bogotá desde la
confederación de padres bueno aquí aquí
hay una gran experiencia que nos ha
dejado la pandemia y es el acceder a
nuevas fuentes de aprendizaje y de
información si bien colombia no estaba
preparada nos desnudó en las realidades
de la educación nos permitió realmente
ser innovadores y creativos y a tener el
aprovechamiento y digamos el compromiso
tanto de la familia como de los
educadores particularmente muchas
escuelas y colegios se reinventaron la
escuela a través de la educación virtual
se crearon nuevas herramientas de
trabajo nuevas metodologías nuevas
estrategias que han permitido a su vez a
pesar de que la familia no se
involucraba tanto en el proceso de
enseñanza-aprendizaje
proactivamente pues logró hacer que los
padres asumiéramos un compromiso y nos
resolvieron las situaciones al interior
del hogar estos retos tanto para la
familia como para los colegios ha sido
fundamental en el desarrollo de el
aprendizaje de los niños obviamente que
hay un impacto de carácter psicosocial y
psico emotivo en los niños se llama
salud mental muchos niños están
afectados hoy en día porque se presume
que como la costumbre del niño es la
interacción personal en tocarse el reír
exaltar el abrazarse con sus compañeros
y compartir espacios y escenarios pues
los afectados digamos el aislamiento en
el hogar pero a su vez hay un rescate
importante que es que ha logrado agrupar
familias ha logrado volver a que la
familia miren a sus hijos a que sus
hijos miren hasta las familias a los
padres a que haya un mayor
aprovechamiento de escenarios
intrafamiliares con mejor elaboración de
carácter pedagógico
en que los padres se involucren en no
solamente en guiar y orientar a sus
hijos de él hacer en vigilar los para
que hagan cumplan con las labores
académicas sino el re aprendizaje de
muchos padres de familia que habían
abandonado también el estudio en las
escuelas los en los colegios señor 20
hasta por 30 años pero que
afortunadamente ahora con esta con este
reto pues los padres hemos vuelto un
poco de alguna manera a la escuela
y continúo con usted señor ballesteros
para comenzar esta siguiente ronda de
preguntas con los invitados y como debe
ser entonces ese regreso a clases yo
entiendo que depende mucho del caso de
cada uno de los países no es lo mismo
uruguay que le ha ido muy bien con el
manejo de la pandemia otros países como
perú donde el contagio ha sido mayor y
la situación ha sido más difícil de
llevar pero cómo cree usted que debe ser
ese regreso a las clases presenciales y
también le pregunto esto dejará secuelas
en los alumnos en términos de la
interacción social de su aprendizaje a
sociabilizar con las personas que los
rodean por estar confinados durante
tantos meses solamente con su entorno
familiar
bueno aquí hay dos cosas importantes que
los expertos especialmente los
psicólogos y psiquiatras también
plantean y es que el ser humano pues
aunque es un ser interactivo y actuante
en la sociedad también hay que entender
que por ejemplo los niños cuando son
pequeños permanecen al cuidado y en el
seno de la familia y no por ello se
atrofia no por ello se enferman yo creo
que eso es un mito es una digamos unos
miedos que han contribuido diferentes
fuentes de información y sobre todo los
mismos actores de la educación y los
mismos ciudadanos a generar el miedo y
las taras en los estudiantes yo creo que
un año que se aplace un año que se
pierda escolar no genera tanto problema
en la sociedad o en los niños como la
pérdida de un hijo por afectación del
coronavirus nosotros particularmente
hago una apropiación aquí del tema
fuimos víctimas nosotros con mi familia
del virus y apenas estamos saliendo
recién recuperación entonces cuando uno
ha sentido el dolor en carne propia pues
poder hacer recomendaciones y
previsiones como puede ser el retorno el
retorno
primero como lo ha dicho la ministra de
educación en colombia mientras no haya
una voz de los padres autorizadas de
cada padre de familia que se comprometa
a sí o no con el retorno a la
presencialidad oa la alternancia
educativa previo el cumplimiento de
todos los protocolos de bioseguridad que
de paso en colombia todavía no están
determinados en concreto en cada
institución pues seguramente no será muy
lento el regreso muy centro muy lenta la
alternancia educativa si se quiere yo
creo que hay que generar una regulación
común que con todos los actores de la
educación
aquí en color que hay en el mundo es
decir
si estábamos conversando con carlos
ballesteros sobre cómo debería ser ese
retorno a las clases presenciales 1 a la
conversación a david pérez que lo había
presentado al inicio del programa eres
dirigente estudiantil representante ante
el consejo permanente multisectorial
para la implementación del compromiso
nacional de la por la educación en la
república de panamá le preguntó el señor
pérez cómo debe ser ese regreso a las
clases desde su punto de vista
buenas noches y por supuesto un gusto
estar aquí con ustedes 324 aquel panamá
lo hemos manejado por fácil ahorita
estamos en esta fase de retorno a clases
de manera a distancia o virtual
le hemos denominado así entonces como
dije va por fases
estuvimos en el dialogo de este nacional
para ver qué podíamos hacer nosotros
para garantizar este derecho a la
educación que está en la declaración de
los derechos humanos artículo 26 del año
1948 entonces lo como lo mencionaba en
un momento vamos a hacerlo por fases
primero de manera virtual y a distancia
que ya se está manejando y hemos tenido
buenos resultados uno de los primeros
países en la región que lo ha estado
manejando así y posteriormente vamos a
ir introduciendo los pistons las clases
presenciales pues pero hemos tomado ya
medidas de bioseguridad para garantizar
primero en la vida y la seguridad de
nuestros estudiantes a nivel nacional
hemos manejado esta situación con mucho
cuidado y obviamente este regreso a la
presencialidad va a depender de el
aumento la disminución de los casos de
kobe 19 en nuestro país y eso también
hay algo muy importante que el oficio
que lo estaba mencionando es que se va a
manejar con el tema de las regiones no
todas las regiones en panamá tienen la
misma tasa de contagios por día entonces
se va también a adecuar por regiones
y así lo hemos manejado en nuestro país
obviamente y como lo mencionaba un rato
manteniendo esta bioseguridad y para que
los estudiantes puedan disfrutar de este
derecho a la educación y principalmente
con calidad y que puedan seguir
avanzando con sus proyectos de vida
continuó con esta ronda con el doctor en
mercado en xalapa en mexico su opinión
como debe ser entonces este regreso a
clases ya nos quedó claro que su opinión
en torno al caso mexicano discrepa de
las medidas que ha tomado el gobierno
[Música]
incremente la precisión federal y la
destreza de los bienes de los estados es
decir cuidar la salud de miles determina
la interacción de las poblaciones en las
escuelas pero tenemos profesores andinos
de edad que posiblemente pudieran estar
en unidades de riesgo que interactúan
con los pequeños ya parece ser que la
evidencia indica detenidos muy pequeños
contactada pero si los niños fruto como
de 10 años en adelante si ya pueden ser
portadores del virus por lo tanto el
derecho a clase tendrá que ser igual con
alimentaba el cólera de panamá va a
tener que ser espaciado en función de
los indicadores de salud y de contar que
usted haya en cada una de las entidades
federativas y dentro de la sociedad
y de derechas
la localidad por lo tanto habrá querido
y por tanto habrá que tener en cuenta
cuáles son los indicadores del despertar
y esther de región del distrito de
estabilidad de alta de una zona
geográfica determinada por municipio
michelle que sea escalonada yo creo que
en este ciclo escolar que se acaba de
echar así dos días hábiles pasado inicio
30 millones de estudiantes de educación
inicial en cali américas empática y
media superior al inicio de clases de la
universidad escuchan en mis letras de
aphex dichas clases el 14 de septiembre
muchas otras universidades
en esas fechas vivirán a cerca de 2 va a
ser hasta el caso de la educación básica
como comunicación iberia a través de
este programa de televisión radio
el texto de la sede presidencial que
sabrá que tener mucha precaución la
entidad estructura esta entidad ésta se
atreve de estabilidad
nada ciudad corporativa menos el espacio
educativo
y finalice esta ronda con la doctora
ángela gentile en la ciudad de buenos
aires es su perspectiva de cómo debe ser
este regreso en el caso argentina pues
ellos han mantenido el año académico
desde marzo hicieron un receso para las
vacaciones de invierno pero enfrentan la
prolongación de la cuarentena enfrentan
también la duración de lo que puede
hacer esta pandemia para el otro año
escolar que comenzaría en marzo
bueno nosotros estamos en una situación
epidémica claramente el epicentro
todavía sigue siendo el amba buenos
aires y la zona de alrededor pero
también el desafío en este momento como
lo comenté antes es el interior del país
en las provincias que sobre todo los
conglomerados urbanos como son sobre
todo rosario mendoza córdoba este es un
virus en que las ciudades se transmite
perfectamente en ciudades vertidos de
las ciudades porque todo lo que es
hacinamiento favorece su transmisión es
por eso la importancia que mirando la
situación epidemiológica se vaya dando
en forma escalonada el regreso a las
clases no puede ser que todo el país que
el argentino es un país muy extenso con
situaciones totalmente diferentes entre
una provincia y otra lo haga en forma
simultánea entonces todos aquellos que
están en fase 4 fase 5 la idea es que
aceleren
combinando lo virtual con lo presencial
eso es uno de los puntos más importantes
los protocolos están hechos estar todo
preparado para eso
con mucho acuerdo de todas las partes y
me parece que a veces falta la decisión
de avanzar hay que vencer también los
miedos uno lo que observa en esta
pandemia es el miedo lucha con el equipo
de salud lo observa en la comunidad pero
realmente hay que entender que el virus
va a estar entre nosotros por lo menos
hasta tener buenas coberturas de
vacunación hacer duro con la nueva
vacuna con el virus está entre nosotros
tenemos que protocolizar tenemos que
aprender a flexibilizar y las clases son
un desafío pero es muy importante la
escuela no solamente lo aprende
aprendizaje
en sí sino también en lo social en lo
emocional en un montón de factores que
hacen la vida de los chicos y esta
interacción docente el niño y sus padres
es fundamental para su crecimiento
emocional por eso es lo que son desafíos
que hay que tener claros y es ir tomando
los preparando los y eso lo que estamos
tratando de hacer muy atentos a que a
medida que la situación epidemiológica
vaya mejorando las provincias se vayan
animando también a poner en práctica
estos protocolos solía comenzar
claramente con este comienzo de la
actividad educativa me queda un poco
menos de tres minutos para finalizar el
programa y para las conclusiones
comienzo con david pérez en esta
pandemia nos dejó grandes lecciones en
cuanto a la virtualidad como ve usted
entonces el escenario educativo a futuro
muy puntual por favor llevarle la
palabra a los cuatro invitados
el escenario educativo que se ve en
américa la tiene en general lo veo
primero como una prueba para luchar por
el futuro de los jóvenes y segundo la
oportunidad perfecta para actualizar el
sistema educativo no sólo desde mi país
sino a nivel de latinoamérica que ha
sido el derecho diría yo
más golpeado y el que tiene a nuestra
región tan empobrecida carlos
ballesteros su conclusión
yo coincido también en que es una gran
oportunidad y un reto y sobre todo que
involucra por fin a las familias en el
hecho educador tiene el re aprendizaje
en la reeducación y obviamente que va a
dar oportunidad los nuevos jóvenes de
conectarse y estar activos con el mundo
no solamente de la interacción de la
inter e interconectividad sino también
con el mundo científico con el mundo del
conocimiento esto es un gran reto una
gran oportunidad y es el momento del
replanteamiento de muchos paradigmas de
la educación y de muchos paradigmas para
la familia también doctor riccardo
mercado en xalapa en mexico en su
conclusión
pero actuar de verdad creativa para
atender los vicios de las naciones
quedan diez años para lograr una
educación para poder permitir que
existan las posibilidades de educación
permanente durante toda la vida versión
del capítulo sí estoy seguro que le
vamos a lograr superar doctora sentí la
dejo de última para el cierre su
conclusión
bueno mi conclusión es que este es una
situación totalmente desafiante hemos
aprendido incorporar las nuevas
tecnologías esto nos ha permitido
comunicarnos más entre nosotros
comunicarnos con otros lugares del mundo
también que es importante para compartir
experiencias
hay que incorporar estas nuevas
tecnologías a la vida de los estudiantes
de los docentes para capacitación y
probablemente han llegado para quedarse
pero el gran desafío es lograr la
conectividad para poder trabajar con
equidad porque cada vez más nuestros
estudiantes en argentina y en américa
latina tienen que tener la oportunidad
de poder conectarse intercambiar y
compartir todas estas experiencias no
tiene que ser sólo para pequeños grupos
que no tiene que ser en una mirada
ampliada para todos los grupos sociales
a los cuatro invitados muchas gracias
por haber compartido con nosotros sus
perspectivas y sus opiniones en torno a
este tema a las conclusiones pues
también los pueden sacar ustedes en casa
las puede compartir con nosotros a
través de las redes sociales tema
complejo tema difícil
el reto interesante reto complicado para
la sociedad de américa latina' hacer
frente a la educación en tiempos de
pandemia gracias por estar con nosotros
feliz noche
[Música]